.
IT IS MODELED ON THE
CONTROVERSIAL TEXAS LAW THAT
ALLOWS CITIZENS TO HELP ENFORCE
INFORMED PAYMENT.
ABORTION IS AT THE CENTER OF
THE U.S. CULTURE WARS.
A BATTLE FOR DOMINANCE BETWEEN
CONFLICTING VALUES.
IT HAS LONG SPLIT THE TWO
POLITICAL PARTIES INTO THE
COUNTRY.
BUT HOW DO THEY GET THIS WAY?
EVANGELICAL CHRISTIAN GROUPS
HAVE RALLIED TO LIMIT ACCESS TO
ABORTION FOR YEARS.
BUT IT WASN'T ALWAYS A
POLITICAL ISSUE FOR THEM.
ENTER FRANCIS SCHAFFER.
AN EVANGELICAL SCHOLAR WHO BUT
SOME PRANK ENCOURAGED HIM TO
CAMPAIGN AGAINST DETROIT VERSUS
WADE, AND THE PITCHER SOME
MOVIES THEY WERE PRODUCING.
IT IS AN EXTRAORDINARY STORY.
WITHOUT THE SHAPERS, THIS
CULTURE WAR MIGHT NOT HAVE BEEN
SO FIRED UP.
IN FRANK'S JOINING ME NOW FROM
BOSTON.
HIS LATEST BOOK IS CALLED, FALL
IN LOVE, HAVE CHILDREN, STAY
PUT, SAVE THE PLANET, BE HAPPY.
FRANK, WELCOME TO THE PROGRAM.
I AM SMILING A LITTLE BIT,
BECAUSE THAT TITLE IS REALLY
VERY CHILLED COMPARED TO SOME
OF THE MORE APOCALYPTIC
LITERATURE AND MOVIES THAT YOU
PUT OUT.
I AM CORRECT IN ASSUMING,
BECAUSE YOU STATED IT, THEN YOU
ARE NOW VERY REGRETFUL OF YOUR
ROLE IN THIS MOVEMENT.
>> YES BUT.
IT IS LIKE HEARING ABOUT
SOMEBODY ELSE'S LIFE.
ON A DIFFERENT PLANET.
I DID THE WORK WITH MY FATHER
IN THE PRO LIFE MOVEMENT IN THE
1970S.
I AM NOW PUSHING 70 YEARS OLD.
THIS IS 50 YEARS AGO.
AND AS I LOOK BACK, I CAN ONLY
SAY THAT NOT ONLY DO I REGRET
THE IMPACT THAT WE HAD, OF
COURSE IT WAS COMPLETELY
UNFORESEEN, ALL THE WAY UP TO
AND INCLUDING THE MURDER OF
ABORTION DOCTORS, THE FACT THAT
NOW IT LOOKS LIKE ROE V. WADE
WILL BE ROLLED BACK BY SUPREME
COURT DOMINATED BY REPUBLICAN
OPERATIVES THAT HAVE TAKEN WHAT
WE DID BACK IN THE 1970S, AND
EXTRAPOLATED THAT OUT INTO A
FUTURE 50 YEARS LATER.
THAT I FIND SHOCKING.
I WOULD DESCRIBE MYSELF AS A
PROGRESSIVE, SOMEONE OF LIBERAL
PRETTY LITTLE VIEWS.
I'M A FATHER AND GRANDFATHER.
FROM THIS PERSPECTIVE IN MY
LIFE, I LOOK BACK ON WHEN THEY
DID IN MY YOUTH.
MAYBE, I GUESS, THE WAY SOME
WITH ON WARTIME EXPERIENCES AND
POLITICAL EXPERIENCES, MAYBE IN
THE 1930S IN EUROPE IF THEY HAD
JOINED ONE OF THE FASCIST
PARTIES.
LIVED TO SEE IT PLAY OUT IN A
WORLD WAR.
I FEEL MUCH THAT LEVEL OF
REGRET.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT
EXACTLY YOU REGRET.
AND HOW EXACTLY YOU WERE
CULPABLE.
THERE YOU ARE, YOUNG MAN.
YOUR FATHER IS PRETTY MUCH
QUESTION.
AND YOU DECIDE TO CONVINCE HIM
TO OPPOSE ROE V. WADE.
WHY DID YOU DO THAT?
HOW DID YOU DO THAT?
WHAT WAS YOUR FATHER'S ACTIONS
AND YOUR ACTIONS AT THAT TIME?
BUT?
>> I HAVE MADE A FILM SERIES
WITH HIM ON URGING CULTURE,
CALLED, HOW SHOULD WE HAVE LIVE?
WHICH WAS NOT ABOUT ROE V. WADE,
BUT WAS ABOUT A CHRISTIAN VIEW
OF ART AND PHILOSOPHY.
TO COUNTER WHAT HE REGARDED AS
SECULAR HUMANISM, THE THREAT OF
SECULAR HUMANISM.
AS WE MAKE THAT SERIES,
INCLUDING THE LAST EPISODE, ROE
V. WADE WAS HANDED DOWN AT THAT
TIME.
AND --
WAS SURGEON AND CHIEF OF
PHILADELPHIA CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL, WHO WOULD SOON BECOME
RONALD REAGAN'S SURGEON GENERAL,
A POLITICAL APPOINTEE.
HE WAS A FRIEND OF MY FAMILY
AND ALSO AN EVANGELICAL
CHRISTIAN.
.
HE CAME TO MY FATHER'S MINISTRY,
IN SWITZERLAND.
EVEN THOUGH IT WAS AMERICAN
SPEAKING MINISTRY.
AND HE TALKED, ME SOMEONE WHO
IS BARELY OUT OF MY TEENS INTO
A VERY STAUNCH ANTIABORTION
POSITION.
HE SAID, YOU TALK ABOUT ROE V.
WADE IN YOUR LAST OPPOSITE OF
HOW SHOULD WE HAVE LIVED.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE YOUR OWN
SERIES.
I HAVE TO BE HONEST.
IT SADDENS ME THAT THE TIME, IT
WAS THE IDEA OF ANOTHER
PAYCHECK.
I WAS MARRIED.
I WAS A TEENAGE FATHER TALKING
ABOUT TEEN PREGNANCY AND
ABORTION.
I WAS LIVING IT.
MY WIFE GINA AND, I WE HAVE
BEEN TOGETHER 52 YEARS NOW, IT
WORKED OUT.
BUT BACK THEN, WE WERE HAVING
--
THIS WE KEPT OUR CHILD,
ABORTION IS HORRIBLE.
I WAS CONVINCED.
I WAS SINCERE.
SO I TALKED MY FATHER INTO
MAKING THIS SERIES.
OF COURSE, ONE OF MY REGRETS
LOOKING BACK IS THAT IT WAS
TOTALLY UNFAIR.
WE WERE IN A COMMUNITY, WE HAD
SUPPORT.
MY PARENTS WERE HELPING ME.
WE WERE LIVING FREE OF CHARGE
IN THE MISSION.
THE IDEA THAT SOMEHOW WE HAVE
HAD THIS CHILD, AND EVERYTHING
TURNED OUT OKAY, SO EVERYBODY
OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO DO THIS WAS
REALLY, YOU HAVE TO BE AN IDIOT
22-YEAR-OLD, WHICH I WAS AT THE
TIME.
SELFISH.
SELF INVOLVED.
DO NOT BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT WAS NOT THE POSITION
MOST PEOPLE WHO ARE FACING
DIFFICULT PREGNANCIES WERE IN.
SO THAT IS HOW IT STARTED.
>> OKAY.
>> I WAS CONVINCED BY EVERETT
KOOP, AND I CONVINCED MY DAD,
THEN WE WENT FROM THERE.
>> SO YOU WENT FROM THERE TO
MAKE THIS FILM WITH EVERETT
KOOP.
THIS ONE WAS CALLED, WHATEVER
HAPPENED TO THE HUMAN RACE?
AGAIN, IT WAS AN ANTI SORT OF
DOCTRINE.
HERE HE, IS IN THE CLIP THAT WE
ARE ABOUT TO SHOW, STANDING
NEAR THE DEAD SEA.
SURROUNDED BY HUNDREDS OF BABY
DOLLS, PLASTIC BABY DOLLS.
THIS WAS TO SYMBOLIZE ABORTED
FETUSES.
THIS IS WHAT WE ARE GOING TO
PLAY FROM YOUR FILM.
>> SALT.
THIS IS THE SITE ON WHICH THE
CITY OF SAW THEM ONCE STOOD.
HERE ON THE DEAD SEA IN ISRAEL.
ONCE HERE, UNDER THIS SOIL
FIELD OF SALT, SAW THEM WITH
THE MOST HUMANLY CORRUPT CITY
ON EARTH.
A PLACE OF EVIL AND OF THAT.
SAW THEM COMES READILY TO MIND
WHEN WE CONTEMPLATE THE EVILS
OF ABORTION, AND THE DEATH OF
MORAL LAW.
>> SO, FRANK.
IT IS A PRETTY EXTRAORDINARY
SIGHT.
AND IT DOES CONJURE UP A WHOLE
DYSTOPIAN WORLD.
BUT YOU ARE NOT A PARTICULARLY
KNOWN FILMMAKER.
YOU ARE A YOUNG MAN.
HOW DID THIS FILM IMPACT AND
GALVANIZE THE ANTI ABORTION
MOVEMENT?
>> FIRST OF ALL.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
THE ONLY REASON I WAS DIRECTING
THE MOVIE --
I'VE BEEN MAKING SUPER FILMS,
FOR THOSE WHO REMEMBER MOVIES,
BACK IN THE DAY, SINCE I WAS
ABOUT 12.
AND I GOT THE JOB PRODUCING HOW
SHE WITHIN LIVE, AND THEN
DIRECTED WHATEVER HAPPENED TO
THE HUMAN RACE, GOT THE
SCREENPLAY FOR MY FATHER AND
INSPIRATION FROM EVERETT KOOP.
BUT IT WAS NEPOTISM, PURE AND
SIMPLE.
I AM SCHAEFFER, MY FATHER WAS A
BIG EVANGELICAL STAR.
AND SO I GOT THE JOB.
IT TURNS OUT I HAD ENOUGH
TALENT TO MAKE A STRONG PIECE
OF PROPAGANDA THAT WAS VERY
EFFECTIVE.
IT WAS AFFECTIVE WITH
EVANGELICAL AUDIENCES.
HERE IS THE THING THAT I THINK
MOST PEOPLE DO NOT UNDERSTAND.
AT THE TIME WE BROUGHT THIS OUT
IN A SEMINAR SERIES IN ABOUT
1978 FOR 1980, EVANGELICALS
WERE NOT INTERESTED.
NOT ONLY THAT, THEY DID NOT
WANT TO KNOW.
OUR FRIEND BILLY GRAHAM, THE
GREAT EVANGELIST, WAS
PRO-CHOICE.
MOST EVANGELICALS DO NOT KNOW
THAT.
HE REFUSED TO PARTICIPATE WITH
US AND OUR SEMINARS EVEN THOUGH
HE MY FOLLOWERS WERE FRIENDS.
HE SAID, FRANK, EVEN JUST A.
HERE I THINK, PEOPLE WOMAN,
OUGHT TO HAVE A CHOICE.
DOCTOR --
OF THE SOUTHERN BAPTIST
CONVENTION, PRESIDENT OF THE
SOUTHERN BAPTIST CONVENTION.
FOR, AMERICANS THEY WILL
UNDERSTAND IT IS THE MOST
CONSERVATIVE GROUP OF
EVANGELICALS IN AMERICAN.
HE WAS PRO-CHOICE.
HE EVEN APPROACHED SERMONS ON
CHOICE.
WE HAD TO CONVINCE
EVANGELICALS.
I THINK A LOT OF COMMENTATORS
LOOKING BACK THINK THAT SOMEHOW
THIS WAS ALWAYS PART OF THE
EVANGELICAL MOVEMENT.
IT WAS NOT.
ABORTION WAS ILLEGAL IN THE
UNITED STATES UP UNTIL THE 19TH
CENTURY AND INTO THE EARLY 20TH
CENTURY, WHEN THE AMERICAN
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION TRIED TO
PUSH WOMEN OUT OF THE MIDWIFE
BUSINESS, AS IT WERE, AND TAKE
THIS OVER FOR PROFESSIONAL
GYNECOLOGISTS AND SO ON.
IT HAS NOT BEEN PART OF
AMERICAN HISTORY TO BE
ANTIABORTION.
IT WAS A NEW PHENOMENON THAT WE
HAD TO TALK EVANGELICALS INTO.
ONCE WE TALK THEM INTO, IT
THERE IS NO BECAME A THING.
REPUBLICAN LEADERS, OUR FRIEND
--
GERALD FORD, THE PRESIDENT.
THEY WILL STAY IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
HIS SON MIKE WAS LIVING IN MY
HIS WIFE JILL WAS BABY SITTING
OR DAUGHTER JESSICA.
IT'S, YEAH IT'S.
AFTER WE WERE VERY CONNECTED TO
THE EARLY STAGES OF THE
RELIGIOUS RIGHT.
ONCE OTHER EVANGELICAL LEADERS
SAW THIS AS AN EASY FUNDRAISING
TACTIC.
TO KEEP PEOPLE ANGRY.
BABIES ARE BEING MURDERED.
WE CAN RAISE MONEY.
I WOULD PEOPLE LIKE JACK KEMP
AND RONALD REAGAN AND OTHER
PEOPLE, WE KNEW, REALIZED, THAT
THE APATHETIC EVANGELICAL
MAJORITY THAT DID NOT EVEN CARE
ABOUT VOTING SUDDENLY COULD BE
ENERGIZED.
BECAUSE THEY HAD LOST THE FIGHT
ON SEGREGATION.
AND THE SEGREGATIONIST LUXURY
FOR, WELL NOW WE GIVE THEM
SOMETHING NEW TO FIGHT FOR.
TWO BIG AGENDAS HAPPENED.
AN ANTI-GAY AGENDA, AND AN ANTI
ABORTION AGENDA.
AND THE ANTIABORTION AGENDA
BECAME THE LITMUS TEST.
THAT IS WHY IT CAUGHT ON.
IT CAUGHT ON BECAUSE MONEY, FUN
REASON BUT EVANGELICAL LEADERS.
AND IT CAUGHT ON BECAUSE THE
REPUBLICAN --
SAID.
THERE'S A POLITICAL GROUP THAT
BARELY, ABOUT HALF OF THEM BUT
FOR, DEMOCRATS WE CAN ENERGIZE
THEM IF WE MAKE THIS INTO A
MORAL CRUSADE.
IT WAS A VERY CONVENIENT THING
FOR REPUBLICAN LEADERS.
>> AND I THINK, ALL THESE
DECADES LATER, IT IS
EXTRAORDINARY TO LEARN FROM YOU
THAT IT WAS NOT A POLITICAL
ISSUE FOR THE EVANGELICALS.
PRETTY MUCH, IT WAS REALLY THE
CATHOLICS.
WHO WERE MOSTLY IN THE
FOREFRONT OF --
>> YEAH.
NOT ONLY WAS NOT A POLITICAL
ISSUE, YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND,
OUR BIG FIGHT WAS WITH
EVANGELICALS.
THE EDITORIAL BOARD OF
CHRISTIANITY TODAY MAGAZINE,
THE FLAGSHIP OF EVANGELICAL
CHRISTIANITY, THEY WERE
PRO-CHOICE AT THE TIME.
THEY REFUSED TO ENDORSE OUR
FILM.
PHILLY, GRAND DOCTOR CRISWELL,
ON AND ON AND ON.
IT CHENEY BECAME A MATTER OF
CONVENIENCE.
--
AND OTHER RIGHT-WING ACTIVISTS.
>> WHAT TIME PERIOD ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT?
WE, KNOW WE JUST MENTIONED, AND
YOU DID, THAT C EVERETT KOOP
WAS PRESIDENT REAGAN'S SURGEON
GENERAL.
AND I WAS AT THE SAME TIME THE
RISE OF WHAT IS KNOWN AS THE
MORAL MAJORITY, WITH A JURY FOR
WELD AND OTHERS.
WHAT'S ACTUALLY CHANGED?
YOU TALKED ABOUT PEOPLE
REALIZING THAT IT IS A
FUNDRAISING ISSUE AND THAT THEY
COULD FIRE UP THE BASE THE BASE,
SO TO SPEAK.
WHAT'S THE PROCESS OF MAKING IT
INTO THE ISSUE THAT IS TODAY?
>> WE MADE A GOOD FILM SERIES,
IF YOU WANT TO CALL IT GONNA
TECHNICAL SENSE.
IT HAD A HUGE IMPACT ON PEOPLE.
AND THE AUDIENCE BEGIN TO GROW.
THEN WE BECAME PICKETED BY
PEOPLE LIKE THE NATIONAL --
AND OTHER PRO-CHOICE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT STARTED
GETTING INTO THE NEWS.
BUT WILL REALLY CHANGE WAS MY
FATHER AND I WOULD GO AROUND
TALKING TO PEOPLE LIKE JERRY
WILL FALWELL, AND CONVINCING
THEM THIS IS GOING TO BE A BIG
THING.
AN ISSUE.
AND THAT IS ONE WHERE MY FATHER
REALLY PLAYED AN INSTRUMENTAL
ROLE.
ON TWO FRONTS.
ONE, TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
EVANGELICAL CHRISTIANS BEGIN
WATCHING THESE FILMS INSIDE THE
SEMINARS AND CHURCHES AND
SCHOOLS AND HIGH SCHOOLS AND SO
FORTH.
AND THEN THE NEXT THING THAT
CHANGE WAS, WE BEGIN TO
CONVINCE THEM THROUGH THE FILMS
THAT WERE VERY EFFECTIVE AS
PROPAGANDA.
AND THEN THE NEXT THING WOULD
HAPPEN IS THAT LEADERS LIKE
JERRY FALWELL WHO HAD BEEN
SEGREGATIONIST DECIDED HIS NEXT
BIG ISSUE IS GOING TO BE TO
FIGHT THE GAY RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
AND THE PRO LIFE MOVEMENT.
HE WOULD ADOPT THESE THINGS AS
A KIND OF CLARION FAULT TO HIS
PEOPLE.
THEY WERE TALKED INTO THE SPY
MY DAD.
AND BEFORE THAT, THEY HAD NOT
BEEN IN THIS CAMP.
>> AND THEY USE YOUR FILMS, AS
YOU YOURSELF SAY, VERY
EFFECTIVE WELL MADE VISUAL
PROPAGANDA.
THAT YOU WERE ABLE TO USE AND
THEY WERE ABLE TO USE.
I DO THINK SOMETHING IS
EXTRAORDINARY, WHICH MAYBE OUR
VIEWERS WILL REMEMBER.
THAT ALSO, FALWELL AND THE
MORAL MAJORITY, THEY WERE
TRYING TO US FROM POWER AND
DENY A SECOND TERM TO THEN
PRESIDENT JIMMY CARTER.
THEY WERE TRYING TO GET RONALD
REAGAN IN.
AND OF COURSE, JIMMY CARTER WAS
THE FIRST EVANGELICAL CHRISTIAN
TO BE PRESIDENT.
YOU WOULD THINK THEY WOULD LIKE
THAT.
WHAT IS THAT WE ARE TWIST?
WHY WERE THEY SO FOCUSED ON
GETTING HIM OUT, AND REAGAN IN?
>> WELL, JIMMY CARTER WAS TOO
DECENT HUMAN BEING.
HE WAS COMPASSIONATE WOMAN.
HE WAS PRO-CHOICE.
HE WAS NOT A RACIST.
HE HAD BEEN INCLUDED ON
INTEGRATION.
HE WANTED TO INCREASE VOTER
RIGHTS FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS.
CARRIE FALWELL WAS A
SEGREGATIONIST.
HE WAS A FAR-RIGHT WINNER.
HE WAS A HOMOPHOBE.
AND A NASTY PIECE OF WORK.
AS SIMPLE AS THAT.
BASICALLY, GARY FALWELL AND
THESE OTHER GUYS COULD NOT
MANIPULATE JIMMY CARTER.
HE WAS AN EVANGELICAL CHRISTIAN
AND A BIBLE TEACHER, LITERALLY,
IN SUNDAY SCHOOL.
HE WAS IN THEIR MIND THE WRONG
KIND OF CHRISTIAN, BECAUSE THEY
HAD SO FAR POLITICIZE THEIR
VISION OF THE GOSPEL THAT THEY
WERE FAR MORE INTEREST IN THE
POLITICS AND THE WAR IN, IF YOU
WANT TO PUT AN EVANGELICAL
TERMS, SHARING THE LOVE OF
JESUS.
THIS IS NOT A TRUSTED THESE
GUYS ANYMORE.
THEY WANTED TO WIN ON ACTIONS.
THEY WANT ACCESS TO POWER.
AND THEY GOT.
IT OF COURSE, IN DONALD TRUMP,
YOU HAVE THE APOTHEOSIS 50
YEARS LATER.
WHERE THIS GROUP, NOT THESE
INDIVIDUALS BUT THE GROUPS THAT
THEY LEFT BEHIND, BECAME
TOTALLY POLITICIZED.
AND WE NO LONGER EVEN A
RELIGION ANYMORE.
BUT A POLITICAL MOVEMENT OF THE
FAR-RIGHT.
>> AND VERY VERY EFFECTIVE
LEGAL MOVEMENT TO.
THAT HAS WAGE THIS CAMPAIGN.
IT HAS NOW GOT TO WHERE, YOU
MENTIONED DONALD TRUMP.
THEY GOT HIM IN BASED ON THE
PROMISE TO NAME ANTIABORTION
JUDGES.
WHICH HE DID.
THREE OF THEM.
AND THIS IS WHERE WE ARE RIGHT
NOW.
I JUST WANT TO, READ FOR YOU, A
STATEMENT AFTER THE LEAGUE OF
THE SCOTUS RULING, BY THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
EVANGELICALS.
THEY SAY, EVANGELICAL
COMMITMENTS TO PROTECTING THE
UNBORN STEMS FROM OUR DEEP
UNDERSTANDING THAT GOD CREATED
HUMAN BEINGS IN HIS IMAGE.
AND EVERY HUMAN LIFE FROM
CONCEPTION TO DEATH HAS
INESTIMABLE WORTH.
ONE HAS TO, OF COURSE, TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT THE RELIGIOUS
BELIEFS, THE MORAL POLICE,
SOMEONE EVEN SAY THE SCIENTIFIC
BELIEFS, IN THIS STATEMENT.
TALK TO ME ABOUT THAT.
BECAUSE THAT IS ALSO PART OF
THE STORY.
THERE IS A BIG PART OF THE
COUNTRY AND THE WORLD WHO
BELIEVES PRECISELY THAT.
YEAH, FIRST OF ALL, THE
EVANGELICALS DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT.
IF THEY DID, THEY WOULD BE
FIGHTING FOR PAID PARENTAL
LEAVE, SO FATHERS AND MOTHERS
COULD GO HOME AND BE WITH THEIR
CHILDREN, INSTEAD OF WOMEN
GOING BACK TO WORK, THREE LOW
PAID JOBS THE TERRIBLE MINIMUM
WAGE, WHILE THEY ARE STILL
BLEEDING FROM A CAESAREAN
SECTION.
EVANGELICALS DON'T CARE ABOUT
THAT.
THEY WOULD NOT HAVE FOUGHT AS
THE REPUBLICANS DID AGAINST THE
CHILD TAX CREDIT THAT, FOR A
BRIEF SHINING MOMENT, LIFTED
MILLIONS OF AMERICAN CHILDREN
OF POVERTY.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO SPEND
THAT MONEY, THEY WANT TO GET
RID OF IT, THEY CALL IT
SOCIALISM.
IF HIS GROUP OF PEOPLE WERE
PRO-LIFE AND WERE CONSISTENT IN
THE PRO LIFE POSITION, YOU
COULD HAVE SOME ADMIRATION FOR
THEM, WHILE DISAGREEING ON THE
MATTER OF CHOICE.
BUT THEY ARE AN ANTI FAMILY
GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO PUT THE
WELFARE OF BILLIONAIRES IN THIS
COUNTRY AHEAD OF CHILDREN,
AHEAD OF WOMEN, AHEAD OF POOR
PEOPLE, AHEAD OF FAMILIES.
THEY ARE NOT EVEN FOR PAID
PARENTAL LEAVE, THEY ARE NOT
FOR THE CHILD TAX CREDIT, THEY
DO NOTHING FOR CHILDREN IN
TERMS OF SCHOOLS AND EDUCATION.
THEY HAVE NEVER RAISED WHEN
MINIMUM WAGE.
THEY BELIEVE IN WORKING PEOPLE
2 TO 3 JOBS ON THE EDGE OF
POVERTY, TOUGH LUCK, YOU'RE ON
YOUR OWN.
FROM THE MINUTE THAT CHILD IS
BORN, THEY ARE ANTI-LIFE, THEY
ARE NOT JUST ANTICHOICE.
THIS IS A HYPOCRITICAL
MOVEMENT.
I WANT TO SAY SECOND THING.
WHEN IT COMES TO THESE MORAL
ISSUES OF CHOOSING LIFE, IT ALL
IS A MATTER OF TRUST.
WHO DO WE TRUST?
DO WE TRUST JUDGES ON THE
SUPREME COURT WHERE THE FEDERAL
BENCH WAS PUT THERE BY DONALD
TRUMP IN A BARGAIN WITH RALPH
REID, AND THE OTHER EVANGELICAL
LEADERS.
IT WORKED.
OR DO WE TRUST WOMEN?
BUT WE HAVE TO TRUST SOMEONE.
AND ME, PERSONALLY, IF I'VE
LEARNED ANYTHING OVER THE LAST
70 YEARS OF BEING A FATHER AND
GRANDFATHER, AND SOMEONE WHO
DOES CHILD CARE FOR MY OWN
CHILDREN AND GRANDCHILDREN,
IT'S THIS.
IF YOU DON'T TRUST WOMEN, WHY
WOULD YOU TRUST A GYNECOLOGIST?
A MILE --
MALE, WHITE, GYNECOLOGIST.
IF YOU DON'T TRUST WOMEN TO
MAKE CHOICES, WHY WOULD YOU
TRUST A GROUP OF NINE JUDGES,
INSTEAD OF THE INDIVIDUAL WOMAN
IN MAKING THE CHOICE?
I TRUST WOMEN.
DOES THAT MEAN I THINK WOMEN OR
MEN OR NON-BINARY PEOPLE,
WHOEVER, ALWAYS MAKE THE RIGHT
CHOICE?
NO.
BUT YOU'VE GOT TO GIVE SOMEONE
THE CHOICE IN THESE MATTERS,
ALL MATTERS, WHERE AN --
TO LIVE A GAY LIFESTYLE, TO BE
NON-BINARY, WHATEVER.
THESE ARE CHOICES THAT BELONG
TO INDIVIDUALS.
THEY DO NOT BELONG TO THE
STATE.
AND SO WHEN YOU SEE WHAT'S
HAPPENING NOW, YOU UNDERSTAND
THAT IT'S NOT GOING TO END
THEIR.
>> THAT'S WHAT I WAS GOING TO
ASK YOU, FRANK.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS GOING TO
FINISH UP WITH.
BE BECAUSE YOU ARE VERY
PASSIONATE NOW, YOU OBVIOUSLY
REGRET DEEPLY HOW YOUR TALENT
GOT THE U.S. TO THIS POINT IN
TERMS OF THE CULTURE WAR.
BUT WHAT DO YOU THINK WILL
HAPPEN NEXT?
BECAUSE WE SPOKE TO THE
OPPOSING VIEW YESTERDAY ON HIS
PROGRAM.
WE GAVE FOR PLENTY OF TIME TO
LAY OUT HER POSITION.
AND SHE SAID NO, THE FACT THAT
WE DON'T WANT ABORTION DOESN'T
MEAN THAT WE'RE GOING TO
LOBBYING TO TURN BACK GAME ERIC,
INTERRACIAL MARRIAGE, OR ANY OF
THE OTHER HUMAN RIGHTS ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN ADJUDICATED BY
THE SUPREME COURT.
DO YOU BELIEVE THAT?
>> OF COURSE NOT.
LOOK AT GORSUCH, LOOK AT THESE
PEOPLE THAT SAT THERE IN THE
SENATE CONFIRMATION HEARINGS,
AND LOOKED RIGHT INTO THE EYES
OF THE SENATORS AND SAID, WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A STATED
PRINCIPLE THAT WILL NOT BE
CHANGED.
THEY GAVE THEIR WORD.
THEY SAID THEY WOULD NOT CHANGE
IT.
THESE PEOPLE ARE POLITICAL
IDEOLOGUES.
AND THE SAME IDEOLOGY THAT
TAKES AWAY THE RIGHT TO CHOOSE
IS GOING TO TAKE AWAY THE RIGHT
GAME ERIC.
THE SAME IDEOLOGY THAT IS NOW
CHANGING THE LAW IN STATE HOUSE
AFTER STATE HOUSE IN FAVOR OF
REPUBLICAN GERRYMANDERING, AND
THE KIND OF THING THAT DONALD
TRUMP SAID WHERE HE'S CLAIMING
TO BE PRESENT SOMEHOW.
AND NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN, VOTING
RIGHTS ARE IN QUESTION.
IF YOU GO BACK 40 YEARS AGO AND
ASKED GERALD FORD, OR ANY OF
THESE PEOPLE, ARE YOU EVER
GOING TO BE PART OF A
REPUBLICAN PARTY THAT IS GOING
TO PUSH AGAINST VOTER RIGHTS
FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS?
THEY WOULD'VE SAID, THAT'S
NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN.
IT'S HAPPENING NOW.
AND SO IF ANYONE THINKS THAT
THESE PEOPLE --
I HAVE TO EXPLAIN SOMETHING TO
YOU, YOU HAVE AN IRANIAN
BACKGROUND, YOU'RE GOING TO GET
THESE WORDS.
WE ARE TRYING IN THIS COUNTRY
TO FIGHT AGAINST PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOT JUST DEMOCRATS, BUT ANYONE
WHO IS IN DEMOCRACY.
PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE IN A
THEOCRACY, AND WHAT THESE
PEOPLE WANT IS A CHRISTIAN
WHITE NATIONALIST VERSION OF
WHAT YOU HAVE IN IRAN TODAY,
AND SAUDI ARABIA.
IF YOU WANT TO LIVE IN THAT
COUNTRY, THAT IS WHERE WE ARE
HEADED.
>> FRANK SCHAFFER, YOU ARE
THERE